i might just mute you to only talk oh
yeah yeah you're gonna [ __ ] with me hey
did you see did you see mike tyson oh my
god dude yeah yeah so tell me your take
i'll i'll bring up some videos while
you're telling me yeah i i watched a few
of the the clips that right that are
available so from what i understand
i was reading about the mike tyson you
know
uh situation right
here's what i understand the guy was
harassing mike tyson from behind the
seat behind he kept and i have a video
of that right right and he kept it you
know coming at him coming at him coming
at him annoying him i guess at one point
there was another video from across the
guy even mentioned mike tyson offering
him shrooms now for people who don't
know mike tyson has come a very long way
from the mike tyson that bit off
holyfield's ear
uh when we were well when some of us
were kids
but
he is he has come a very long well mike
i don't know if people know this mike
tyson went to prison right he went to
prison he he is a he is someone who
who smoke i think i saw somewhere that
uh he spends 40 000 or something crazy
like that in terms of just like
uh
weed cannabis marijuana products which
is insane
that's what he uses personally that's
what i guess that's what he uses
personally now 40 grand wait wait 40
grand how how long over a period is this
that's a month
40 grand a month that's what i heard
that's what that's gonna person can can
a person actually
i know that much product look
well here's the other thing too so not
only does mike tyson just
consume marijuana uh in various forms he
also does shrooms right
and he also has his own uh edibles that
are called mike's bites oh [ __ ] so he
has his own brand of some of these
products yeah yeah so he has his own
brand as well they're little they're
little mini
ears are hilarious oh yeah so so it's
kind of like it's kind of like uh
uh uh
you know these famous like puff daddy
has a vodka mike tyson yeah it's an
edible exactly here that you bite yeah
little edible bites i i wonder how i
wonder how holyfield feels about that by
the way well
i don't know i mean they did they did
make up they had like right right the
episode i know maybe maybe their
partner's in on it maybe it's like a
mold right yeah who knows i don't know
who exactly who the partnership is but
here what i will say is
he he
he consumes marijuana in various forms
he's got his own brand for edibles and
then he also does shrooms this guy has
come a very long way he had a broadway
show which was like more where he worked
with spike lee
yeah he had mike tyson we're talking
about the same mike tyson mike the guy
with the base tattoo he was a boxer okay
yeah yeah he made a couple cameos in uh
in the hangover series yeah i've seen
i've seen that i didn't know he had his
own brother
in many ways he's come uh come a long
way right he lost a lot of weight as
well there's a lot there's like mike
tyson has performed his his ways and
he's right now he's very chill he's also
the guy that if people don't remember
not too long ago there was a guy that
came at him with a gun
and how did he deal with it he gave him
a hug
what yes what was this at like in a
restaurant or some [ __ ] uh
hold on well you pull that up i'm gonna
play this video on the um um
on the plane so this i think this is the
guy who gets his ass kicked by mike
this this perspective that we're seeing
is one of his buddies
because he's kind of talking to this you
see this guy because also he also has
perspective because he says in the video
he's like he gave him shrooms like you
offered him shrooms to be like chill the
[ __ ] out man like you need something to
relax right oh mike tyson offered this
guy shrooms yeah oh
i see so mike wasn't just like hey dude
if you don't leave me to [ __ ] alone i'm
gonna i'm gonna handle it he was like
look here here's some here's some love
man right here's like
again i will play can you bring shrooms
on a plane i guess if you're mike tyson
well i guess
well here dogs aren't like when it comes
to drug sniffing dogs uh shrooms are not
the top priority right okay uh um how do
you know this how do you no
i'm just i'm just i'm just curious how
you yeah it sounds like you're an expert
on getting drugs through an airport i'm
just uh
i don't i don't know tony why
tony shut it down shut it down
i'm just i'm just i ask the questions
that that american people want to know
here no that's totally get hey listen i
get it you got to ask the tough
questions right exactly how i know these
things
may or may not uh be revealed so so what
you're saying
you're saying that you're saying that
shrooms are easier to get there an
airport though because the dogs aren't
yeah i'm just actually hitting on them
yeah yeah they're just it's just not
something that so it is feasible that
tyson had shrooms on him
yeah totally possible he could you know
it's just they just don't show up real
oh there you go boom
don't jump on drugs i said don't show up
on drug test either well i i don't know
about that yeah um
gabe probably knows
well i haven't been
a thing i haven't been drug tested for
those things you know in a situation but
i
you know what i'm just going to stop
talking about we've been talking a lot
about drugs yesterday was 4 20 we talked
about right right right
yeah when it comes to these things
they're not like oh we gotta step out
they're typically gonna look like for
you know cocaine or heroin or marijuana
or something like that but like shrooms
is definitely not a high priority also
because it's becoming decriminalized
uh in some areas like well i mean well i
mean
right well most drugs most drugs should
be right no totally yeah not not not to
legal but decriminalized where you're
not you're not you know you're not
facing decades in prison because you've
got to join on you that's right exactly
um but janie says gabe does his own
research yeah i'm sure he does his own
does his own
research anyways um yeah so here is the
here's the video let's watch this real
quick it's not very long at all but uh
now pay attention to this this guy right
here because mike tyson if you see this
he's kind of in the seat up here by the
window
are they referring to a dave chappelle
episode that sounds like they're
referring to dave chappelle
episode that at the end
again
yeah
they're talking about like charlie
murphy um
don't know if i know that one
they should have never gave you money
um where
you know when um
rick james goes and puts his feet on
their couch i didn't put my feet on
eddie murphy's yeah yeah sure i put my
rocky okay right right right okay i
think that's i think that's what they're
quoting there um
because they say the n-word and course
it's bleeped on this video but they say
the n-word so they're they're saying
racial slurs but i'm not i'm not sure
let's finish the video here that blue
man flight
and boy just got beat up by mike tyson
[Laughter]
oh look at this guy [ __ ] up for sure
and i guess mike's still sitting there
right so the did the marshalls did the
marshalls take mike mike no because
there's another there's another bit
where uh he
he gets pulled off by another guy like
he's like wailing on him after he's
being hurried tyson's tyson's pulled off
tyson is pulled off in another video
tyson has pulled off
um
i mean how drunk do you have to be
to be [ __ ] with mike i mean really
come on
it's i i don't know if it's drunk or if
it's just stupid but if mike tyson says
hey man cool it
if someone that he's weird says hey cool
it and you know it's mike tyson and
you're [ __ ] going at him and he says
hey man
just
just like stop right right and he
probably told him several times because
again i'm gonna show you a video with a
guy with a gun and he hugs him mike
tyson is now someone who's like totally
is a is
way more chill than he was once when he
was originally boxing
this guy
has
hands for weapons right i mean yeah i
don't care how old he is
like even if mike tyson gets in his 80s
you are not going to want to just [ __ ]
with mike tyson like not not only you
know he'll he'll slow and he won't be as
strong yeah but there is an art to
throwing a punch like like this guy is
an artist and throwing punches like
that's what he's famous for he is
[ __ ] this guy
he is paid
to knock
people out right to pound their faces in
okay let's let's watch here's another
video let's let's watch this one here i
think this might be the one where he's
actually um throwing down on the guy
yeah here's where he's throwing down on
the guy right right mike mike come on
let's go stop back
[Music]
i don't really i mean i'm not i'm saying
that i don't think mike tyson should
have punched this game really on a
flight no i look look yeah i'm not
saying he should have but if you're
gonna go with like hey we live in a
consequence-led culture right like you
took you you you made an action you
decided he said hey you stop leaving me
the [ __ ] alone leave me alone let me
even offer some shrooms right like the
guy made a peace offering and then some
drunk
douchebag behind him decides hey you
know what i'm going to keep poking the
[ __ ] bear because this is hilarious
right i'm going to i'm going to poke the
bear he's going to deck me in the face
just not a good idea no
show us this video go ahead yeah yeah
what's this video that you get get up
out of here
so you guys got a gun right there i'm
joking bro
mike i'm out of here
hey i love you fam salute to all your
accomplishment for real if it wasn't for
you we wouldn't have no inspiration i
love you on g for real from the heart
for real respect
i told you i'm just joking bro come on
man come on
i'm out of here i should have pulled
that out they don't call it
when mike tyson tells you to come over
here
[Music]
uh this was back uh this is last month
march 23rd is when my video dropped hey
you're good you're good
yeah you're a sucker you're a [ __ ] ass
put your brains out from there buddy
hey you did good you did good just let
him go he just he on cloud he on cloud
hey thank you mike give it up for mike
[ __ ] tyson
[ __ ] time
mike tyson
is just sitting down
well yeah he's mike tyson what is he
just yeah no he's just sitting down
totally chill boom guns pulled put back
in the pants the threats are made and
he's like no no come here come here
and he hugs him out like
like that's also one of the things that
like most people probably like hey look
uh
security go deal with this guy i'm about
to leave to avoid this situation and
escalating even further and then mike
tyson says no come here come here come
here
hugs it out like who does that who
in their right mind does that i mean
mike tyson is crazy but right
like this goes to show you that if
someone
is pissing if someone is pissing him off
that much on a plane
and a guy had a gun and waved it around
and he was willing to hug that guy
and and the other dude he was willing to
punch
hmm
you know here's here's the thing is
because this is harking back to um the
recent oscars where we'll right right
slap chris rock
for a joke you know rather this guy was
joking on the plane or not or you know
whatever you want to say
um
the fact of the matter is is that you
know you really you shouldn't be getting
violent but i'll tell you where i come
from where i come from
um if you pull the gun on someone
and you were serious about it you better
be really serious about it like really
[ __ ] serious because
you're almost positive that when the gun
came out there you heard it
right you know well the other thing even
even like in um in the situation on the
plane or even in will smith situation
and i said this i think we said this on
the show where i come from if will smith
would have walked up on the stage and
hit someone
like like me or where i come from we
wouldn't you just don't [ __ ] stand
there especially when you do a
follow-through and you walk off you
would not turn your back on someone you
just punched right that is not a thing
that you do
where i come from you would you would
you would if you're gonna throw hands
you're gonna throw hands and
uh i i assume that mike tyson's from the
same kind of
place that i'm from where you where if
you're gonna if you're gonna [ __ ] with
someone you're gonna [ __ ] with someone
and and the gun video only proves that
maybe more
when this guy isn't really serious and
mike tyson's like you're not going to
shoot me right the [ __ ] out here i might
tell you how to shoot me and he gives
him a hug so yeah i do want to play on a
plane on a plane you just can't get out
of that situation but you know you're
out and about you can walk away or
whatever but one of those moments where
it's like he's like [ __ ] man i'm done oh
is this insane this is i know where
exactly where this is well you know
this this may this may or may not be
someone mike tyson punch i just want to
play this real quick
i'm just saying i would not i would i
would not find any context for this yeah
go ahead go ahead so i used to live down
the street that's not dolores that's
right next to dolores park there's a a
decent hill that's right there that
starts up and goes down the length of
dolores park right now what they're
doing right there is those skateboarders
are bombing down a hill and every year
there is a meet-up right there's also
footage of um i don't know if that's a
recent
is that recently i have no idea oh okay
it's just a video it's get it's a video
because every year every year they have
this i've seen ones where cops roll up
where cops
uh like hip checked people on
skateboards as they were halfway down
the hill and knocked them off really
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that they did in san
francisco but this is something that
usually happens every year and they line
up and down the hill and you bomb it
straight where you're just
speeding down the hill on a skateboard
um it's a ton of fun to watch
and
uh happens in san francisco and it's in
the mission so anyone who lives there go
check it out yeah it would be fun to
watch these people flying down the hill
like that yeah yeah it's very impressive
i'm like [ __ ] i i'm like look i'll like
sit on the edge of on the edge of a
building and like take photos and stuff
but i will not bomb down a hill on this
game well yeah that that sounds really
stupid almost as stupid as [ __ ] with
mike tyson on a flight right